If you recall the tragedy of Heath
Ledger and his postumous Oscar win,
you might be surprised to learn he wasn’t
the first to win the award after he died.
A few other actors have also given Academy Award
winning performances and then passed away shortly
after. All these actors are recalled for
their great, award winning performances.
In a career spanning decades, Henry Fonda left an
indelible mark on the history of American cinema
as one of the most identifiable movie stars of his
generation. An actor known for taking roles that
emphasized his own American ideals, Fonda compiled
a robust collection of credits. His best-known
films include Young Mr. Lincoln, The Grapes of
Wrath, and 12 Angry Men. He also launched the
Fonda acting dynasty, which includes his children
Jane and Peter and his granddaughter Bridget.
Despite his many acting achievements, much of
Fonda's career went unnoticed by the Academy.
He was nominated for Best Actor for The Grapes of
Wrath in 1941, and nominated as a producer for 12
Angry Men in 1958, but as Fonda entered his 70s,
he had yet to win an Oscar. That changed with On
Golden Pond, in which he co-starred with fellow
screen legend Katharine Hepburn as an aging couple
trying to mend family fences. The film earned
Fonda and Hepburn Best Actor and Best Actress
Oscars, respectively, giving Fonda his first
and only Oscar win. He died of heart failure
just a few months later, in August of 1982, at
the age of 77. Hepburn acted only sporadically
after On Golden Pond and lived largely in
quiet retirement until her death in 2003.
After beginning his career
on the stage and in radio,
Peter Finch built a reputation as a
powerful acting presence on the big screen,
and by the 1950s he was off and running,
earning international acclaim for films
like A Town Like Alice, The Nun's Story, and
The Trials of Oscar Wilde. Today, though,
Finch is best remembered for his role as
Howard Beale in the 1976 classic Network.
Beale, a devoted newsman who grows fed up with his
network's efforts to put profit over journalistic
integrity, allowed Finch to exercise every ounce
of fiery energy he had. His delivery of one
particular line cemented his place in countless
montages of the greatest movie lines of all time.
"I'm as mad as hell, and I'm
not going to take this anymore."
Network was one of the most acclaimed films
of 1976, and it earned Finch his second Oscar
nomination. Sadly, in January of 1977, the day
after he'd appeared on The Tonight Show to promote
the film, Finch died after suffering a heart
attack in the lobby of the Beverly Hills Hotel.
He was 60. In the weeks after he
died, his performance in Network
earned him his first Globe, his fifth BAFTA
Award, and his first Oscar for Best Actor.
At the time of the award, he was the first
actor to ever win a posthumous Oscar.
In a career spanning five decades, Melvyn
Douglas did it all, and to prove it,
he remains one of only two dozen people
to ever complete the Triple Crown
of Acting. He won an Emmy, Tony, and Oscars
for his performances across stage and screen.
Douglas began appearing in feature films in
1931 and quickly established himself as a suave,
quick-witted presence in everything
from The Old Dark House to Ninotchka,
which remains one of his best-known roles today.
He worked regularly in features throughout the
1930s and 1940s, and in the 1950s made the
successful leap to prolific television work.
In 1964, amid a return to making movies,
Douglas won the Oscar for Best Supporting
Actor for his role as Homer Bannon in Hud. That
success led to prolific work well into his 70s,
as he continued to jump from big screen to small
and back again. In 1980, Douglas won his second
Best Supporting Actor Oscar, this time for his
role as Benjamin Rand in Being There. Sadly,
Douglas passed away at the age of 80 in August of
1981, just over a year after his second Oscar win.
Some actors spend their
entire careers sitting in the shadow
of the Oscars, almost touching that
golden statue but never quite grasping it,
despite decades of tantalizing near misses.
That was the case for Geraldine Page. An actress
who began building a name for herself on the stage
in the 1940s, Page gained Academy attention
at the very beginning of her film career,
earning a Best Supporting Actress nomination
for her role opposite John Wayne in Hondo.
Another six nominations followed with no award,
including Best Actress for Summer and Smoke, Sweet
Bird of Youth, and Interiors, and Best Supporting
Actress for You're a Big Boy Now, Pete 'n' Tillie,
and The Pope of Greenwich Village. Then, at
last, came Page's part in The Trip to Bountiful.
Page's performance as an aging woman who wants
nothing more than to return to her rural home
after years away earned her some of the best
reviews of her career. She received Golden
Globe and BAFTA nominations, and she finally
earned the Oscar for Best Actress in 1986.
Sadly, her post-Oscar career
was short-lived. On June 13,
1987, Page was found dead in her apartment at
the age of 62 after an apparent heart attack.
For actors of all ages,
an Academy Award is supposed to be
a gateway to a wider world of acting
options. It's a rocket you can ride
to whatever opportunities you choose.
That should have been the case for Marie Dressler,
and even though she didn't die immediately
after winning her Oscar, what happened in the
aftermath did cut her time tragically short.
Like many performers during this period of time,
the changing Hollywood landscape
proved challenging for Dressler.
She spent much of the 1920s without
being able to book a single film role.
Finally, after struggling financially for years,
the late 1920s and the introduction of sound
brought about a career renaissance for her.
In 1932, Dressler won the Academy Award
for Best Actress for Min and Bill,
a victory that seemed primed to catapult her to
even greater stardom. She launched into more major
films, including Emma and Dinner at Eight, but by
1932 she'd received a critical cancer diagnosis.
Her health slowed her work to a crawl, and
she died in July of 1934 at the age of 65.
We can trace one of the great filmmaking dynasties
in all of Hollywood back to Walter Huston.
He spent two decades working steadily
as a character actor and starting the
Huston line of family filmmakers.
It's perhaps only fitting, then,
that the film for which Huston finally won
his Oscar ended up being a family affair.
In The Treasure of the Sierra Madre, written
and directed by his son, Huston played Howard,
an old-time gold prospector who leads two
younger collaborators in a search for treasure.
Walter Huston won the Oscar for Best
Supporting Actor for his performance
as Howard. His son John won the only
two Oscars of his long career — for
Best Director and Best Adapted
Screenplay — for the film. Sadly,
Walter Huston completed just three more films
before he died in April of 1950 at the age of 67.
Few actors in Hollywood's silent era were lucky
to survive the paradigm-shifting transition to
"talkies" at all, but a lucky few
were able to thrive in both eras.
Alice Brady was one of them, against
all odds. Born into a theater family,
the actress began her career on the stage before
starting to build her silent film resume in 1914.
She worked steadily for several years before
leaving the screen to focus on her stage work.
By the time she returned to the movies in
1933, Hollywood had changed dramatically,
but Brady's talent was still there. She
picked up right where she had left off,
launching a career in the sound era
that included roles in The Gay Divorcee,
Gold Diggers of 1935, and My Man Godfrey, for
which she was nominated for an Oscar in 1937.
Just a year later, in 1938, Brady received her
second Oscar nomination for In Old Chicago,
but the afterglow was to be short-lived. Brady was
diagnosed with cancer and died in
October of 1939 at the age of 46.
Even before his big Oscar buzz, Heath Ledger was
widely recognized as one of the most promising
young actors of his generation. His career
launched on Australian television in the 1990s,
and he was an instant success when he began
appearing in American films like 10 Things
I Hate About You and The Patriot. By the
mid-2000s, he was a full-fledged movie star,
and in 2005 alone he appeared in Casanova,
The Brothers Grimm, Lords of Dogtown,
and Brokeback Mountain. He received Golden
Globe, BAFTA, and Oscar nominations for his
performance in the last film, making him one
of the youngest Oscar nominees in history.
Then came The Dark Knight. Hot
off the success of Batman Begins,
director Christopher Nolan cast Ledger
as his incarnation of The Joker.
While fan skepticism was initially high,
buzz from the set and early looks at the
character quickly built excitement for a
potentially iconic piece of superhero work.
“haha”
Sadly, Ledger did not live to see
the full response to the film.
He died in January of 2008 at the age of
just 28, after an accidental overdose in
his New York City apartment, months before
The Dark Knight was set to premiere. When
the film finally hit theaters Ledger received
near-universal acclaim for his performance,
and earned posthumous BAFTA, Golden Globe,
and Oscar wins for Best Supporting Actor.
That made him only the second actor ever
in history to win an Oscar after his death.